hi I'm John Klum and I'm talking about
placing entered package which is a wolf
language package for working out the
price of wolf from applications and
certain codes business rules and exposes
them over an API function to be used on
business systems within the company
so this is this is an eating your own
dog food type talk because while most of
what we do at Wolfram is about making
clever stuff to give to all of you we
are also still an organization that has
business systems and stuff that needs to
work to keep us running as a company so
in the middle of a project at the moment
to modernize our our entire business
system architecture and this talk is
about one small little fragment of that
that was through my direction as as one
of the few people who is both technical
and as a history and sales so
understands things like how our
licensing works so the problem was to
update the way that we work in a more
modern way there was a strategic
decision to whenever this customization
to use our own technology to reduce
dependency outside and only use outside
tools where that kind of work
off-the-shelf to do something that we
really don't want to try and replicate
and then we have some particular issues
as a software company we have huge
common rhetorical pricing complexity so
I mean I tried to get an estimate that
of the different number of ways you can
buy mathematical in it's somewhere in
the order of ten thousand now a lot of
the business systems around and
certainly some of the ones we're using
are very oriented towards physical
products where your inventory might be
you know to have 10,000 parts you kind
of need to be a Ford Motors or or
whatever but to have 10,000 different
software configurations you know you can
have this sort of explosive number of
them and having systems that are based
around physical inventory where things
have an item number to leave that
specific item that you have to track the
stock of don't really apply to software
so we wanted to kind of simplify the way
we think about our main product line up
and then another problem that we have is
at the moment is a fragmented Authority
so if you want to know the price of the
license Mathematica there's a bunch of
different places you can look and they
are not entirely synchronized and so
whenever we make changes there's a big
challenge to make sure that the prices
that appear on our website that are
presented to customers match the place
that our ordering system expects to be
entered that match what is on the
salespersons desk who answers the
telephone when you ask for clarification
and all of these things are going for
different
and creating a whole sort of authority
complexity that we really just weren't
getting any benefit from so the task I
was given was think about how we could
produce a single Authority that is the
place that sets the place of everything
that we do so that everything else then
can flow out at that point and and and
things are computed so we aren't listing
tens of thousands of different places
now it wasn't just a fix what's broken
type problem I saw this as an
opportunity as well so one thing that I
wanted to get out of this was to try and
expose and therefore hopefully eliminate
inconsistency and you know I have to
bear some of the guilt for this I've
been around for a long time and so since
92 I've probably contributed to some of
the crazy and consistent rules that we
have when you're going through the
placing trying to understand why the
price of a product is what it is some of
the things you're looking at the rules
embedded long in history you have no
idea why there's some weird special case
for the way something works in the UK
compared to somewhere else I mean one I
can remember because I was passed the
decision is the amount of discount you
get for being a student and buying a
student license is different it is in
the UK than it is in the rest of Europe
and and in the u.s. and the reason for
that was on that particular day when we
decided student versions weren't selling
very well in the UK we thought where
there's a psychological point we have to
be under a hundred pounds including tax
so we set it nicely and it made perfect
sense at that time and that was 15 years
ago in inflation's push things up it's
not a nice pound number anymore
but the rule that said that it's a
cheaper ratio compared to a u.s. student
license has persisted long after it had
any use so my past my hope was that we
could we could flush all those things
out and actually have things to be
really consistent around the world so
you don't get weird cases where
something's better value than something
else in one country but in another
country the values the other way around
and of course the the main holy grail of
all of this is can we just be more agile
as a company can we make it easier to
roll out new products to do promos to do
kind of experiments we did an experiment
in the UK just to give a context to this
that was we thought let's try selling at
a slightly higher price
including free training and see if
that's something that helps to get
people into the product better and it
took a team of ten fairly intelligent
people over an hour to argue about how
we could possibly achieve this because
the UK placing was intrinsically linked
into the Scandinavian pricing in the way
that we were architected and I wanted a
system where I could just type one line
of code and that would be it would
happen and you know you could imagine
taking this too extreme one day the
dream might be that we could do a promo
where everyone gets a completely
different promo and machine learning is
feeling out what kind of person responds
to which promo rather than having to
have some human letting a be experiment
we could do an ABCD efg infinity
experiments on and really learn from it
in an automated way but that's that's
dreaming for the future for now so
here's the bit where the Wolfram
technology comes in is how to try and
solve that so this would have broke down
into a few bits one was first of all
could we one thing we want to do is move
away from strings and names of things so
there are products that have complicated
names like like mathematic professional
network increment and separately from a
mathematical professional network
license could we represent the essence
of a software product in a symbolic
expression so this is this is at the
heart what the project was to do it was
to take a symbolic representation of a
request for something that might come
from the store from a customer saying I
want buy Mathematica I am in the United
States I'm not a student or an academic
I wanted to have service I want it to
last forever I don't surrender thing
it's single machine and I want to
download the thing right now and I only
want one of them so this is a set of
keys that encapsulate the essence of a
mathematical license now part of the
complexity is that those keys are fairly
generic across software but they're not
totally generic so the key set might be
slightly different if my my access
control wasn't single machine it's
unlimited if I'm an academic site
licensed they want to buy an unlimited
Mathematica set up then there's an extra
key needed which is the technical
student count so the keys vary by
product so I buy a t-shirt the key might
be size and color
although this really makes more sense
within the software so we needed
flexible ontology for this and this is
basically what the things supposed to do
I put in the keys and it says two
thousand seven hundred dollars in this
case well I could change this thing here
and say let's be in France now and we
compute that and now it switches into
euros and says it's three four four five
euros and if I change my use class to
being a student then we'll get some I
keep the key name is not student I can
what the key use classes for students is
its students plural well okay I
obviously need to know there is some
other issue here no base price premiere
service because student licenses do not
come with premiere service so I actually
have to say service like none there is
no configuration there so pricing
failure is a way for the system saying
that is an invalid request and the
reason is that for that the
configuration you given I can't find
what this product splice should be
although the pollak premier services
place because there is no premiere
service for student Isis so that's the
first step and and you know while I'm
listing all of these things as as
associations actually we're going to
move this over to being much more
integrated into the whorfin language by
everything I'm just going to show here
actually will be entities in the future
so there will be an entity for a product
and an entity for things like the
business rules so the next step then is
to try and move all of the definitions
that these things depend on well away
from the request so what do we wanted to
do is to have the ability to describe
products in to the system in a symbolic
way and so here's the sort of basics of
entity structure of that is it's an
entity type product and it's in this
particular entity is the mathematical
product and then one of the key
properties of the entity is something
that we'll have as a base price for the
thing so we don't have to list out all
of the places every wakes through the
system there's this concept of a base
price and from that we can compute your
actual place depending on whether you
know all of these other dimensions they
showed trying to be as abstracted as
possible
we invented a currency of course
everything's Wolfen around wolfram so we
got a wolf and currency unit and the
idea of that was simply to not have any
one currency be the price that we then
compute from by having something that's
currency independent we can then decide
okay what if we want to raise prices
around the world by by two percent for
inflation this year all we have to do is
change the currency conversion between
this wolfram currency unit and the US
dollar and the pound at the end and in
the Euro we don't have to revisit any of
the definitions so this number will stay
in perpetuity the base price of
mathematic will always be this thousand
and forty eight wolf and currency units
and all it will changes is the is the
conversion over the next decade or so
it's vaguely equivalent to the single
machine annual commercial 2016 dollar
price but that's going to long time that
will be completely forgotten and it'll
be quite an arbitrary number also while
I'm stripping it out here one of the
hopes here is that we can have this
definition not just to find the pricing
of a product but by listing out the
contents that Mathematica contains a
front-end and a kernel and maybe it
contains some some more granular
components we can start describing
actually what what a this name
Mathematica means in a world where we
might have many more configurations of
products that that
wolfin finance platform is just the same
configuration but the contents is longer
because it's got things like Bloomberg
link and Reuters link and the other
things that come with with finance
platform so in one place we can define
everything one would need to know about
a product so profit actually writing the
code all you'd have to do for the
business systems is right there tells
this little entity value and the product
would go live and they'd probably be
keys for short description and long
description that might even populate
things like the store now the complexity
of this is kept down by this concept of
hierarchy and it in a sense I had style
sheets and the mathematical front-end in
in mindfully stood in the front end you
can say and a very local level this word
is in bold but if you want the whole
cell to be bold you could do it at a
soul level or if you in fact you're
using a stylesheet you don't say
anything about that because it goes up
until it says okay we get to the style
for section and that happens to be in
bold so
what I wanted to do was to
hierarchically organized products as
well so that when you create a new
product that is kind of like Mathematica
but some other components you don't have
to spell out hundreds of keys of details
you can just say it's like this product
but this is different so I mean the idea
is it inherits anything that I haven't
said here it inherits from this
mathematical product class and if you
can't find it there it inherits from
software class and if it can't find it
there it goes to product defaults and so
that's where the complexity lives so
here's the software class that this it
ultimately inherits from which is where
all the good stuff lives and one of the
key things here being this price wcu
function so this is where it defines how
all these different dimensions come
together that the pricing for this for
this class is quite simple we just find
these little things called place
multipliers so there is a price
multiplier if you're commercial in a
different one if you're academic and a
different one if you're student and then
we multiply all these multiplies
together and multiplied also by the base
price which is okay there's the base
price look up and there's a time period
scaling I'll maybe mention later and
then there's complexity of service which
I think we can do better a bit at the
moment there's a little bit of code here
that says well if this service you have
to make another lookup for that so all
kinds of stuff lives in here that is
actually computed rather than rather
than values and this is where the whole
wolfing language kind of gets useful
because we've got code for the placing
package and we've got numbers like the
base price but then in the data there
are things that can be code as well so
data and code don't have to be
completely separate so within the
database of all these business rules we
can have little snippets of code that in
say for this particular value
well it's complex you have to do
something to work out what the value is
not just look it up oh and here's
further about that hierarchy needs to
get to see some of the other keys
they're in here there's information
that's needed for for helping things to
be taxable whether or not we can
allocate revenue so if this thing had a
royalty but needed to be paid to
somebody else does that get allocated
trying to make things a little bit
dependent on whether there are costs
involved with things that that'll have
for example services where to actually
cost us money to sell the thing we don't
want to necessarily discount that to be
making a loss and so there's all little
corner details but it's a but it's just
in case
just adding more keys to describe the
concept at the right level in the
hierarchy and so this is at the moment
it's gonna you can see some bits we've
sort of ignored so far this is the map
of the hierarchy so you've got a whole
bunch of applications that follow then
here it from an application class you've
got a whole bunch of mathematical like
products that and then we've got a whole
bunch of things like development
platform tiers that they did inherit
from a development platform inherit from
the software class all leading to
Pollock defaults and we got this mess
we've ignored of miscellaneous so at the
moment t-shirts and pens and posters all
you know it's sack and we're just kind
of ignoring those for now but at some
point you can mention this being a big
hierarchy of t-shirts and onto the
t-shirt all the designs and under each
of the designs all the sizes or whatever
of course we can compute that stuff now
because we have a symbolic
representation of all of these products
in the catalog so we got the product
database that defines the product and
then we have to bring in the business
for so we're keeping those in a separate
place because it's different people who
have to think about them and they have
different kind of structures but they're
actually the same kind of idea they've
got an entity for an entity type of
access control which is how might you
use the software and then the different
entities within that entity type are
things like single machine network
license public to the world like web
Mathematica is unlimited if it's an
unlimited license and then various keys
to go with them that say so these are
the two rules for example that define
how network license is price if you've
got a single machine license we multiply
the place by one I that's the default if
you have a network license network
increments cost thirty percent more than
single machine licenses so in one line
we've encapsulated all network licenses
across the entire product line up and
less we inserting exceptions and this is
where exceptions will really stand out
because you actually have to create a
rule to stop things being automatically
the same rather than at the moment the
thing has been everything needs a rule
and so you don't you always having to
create a rule and so whether you create
one that's the same and consistent or
one that's just random and different is
equally the same effort and now you have
to create a rule to say except in a
certain circumstance those rules will
really stand out and and need defense
and here's how we do this kind of
exceptions is that there's a concept of
restrict
say this particular rule only applies if
the product is in the class of cloud
products so I might actually watch all
of this what this is saying oh it's
saying that there are no cloud only
student licenses which I'm not sure it's
correct actually been out to revisit
that rule but it's saying if you're
asked for a student multiplier but
you're in Oh a cloud only product class
then you're just going to use the
commercial price you don't get a special
deal for students in that group and then
if your student in anything which is
single machine or wolf my debased then
you get a a ninety-three percent
discount compared to the commercial
price and the public will is also going
to be about as I said things like promos
and and time limited things so the idea
is that we have inheritance classes for
different types of promos so here the
parent is something called a price
proportion discount that means it's
going to give you some fraction off the
price but there's about when I
enumerated them about ten different
classes of promo that's like a a a price
combination by this and this and get
something off or there is a a kind of
basket adjustment promo that says if you
buy this and this will give you a free
thing that you didn't ask for in the
basket so there's about a dozen of these
ten or twelve of these different things
this is saying in the case of this it's
a price proportion discount you're going
to ask for a promo code it won't
automatically work on this one and it'll
give you a discount which is going to be
50% off if you buy two of these things
and then it's going to insert a key
first say this is the reason for why
you're being a disc given the discount
it's a buy one get one free discount so
then the process through the system is
to augment keys we start off with just
the keys you asked for is the customer
and when we're done we've inserted all
kinds of keys to say here's the place in
local County here's the reason why we
gave a discount here's the discount we
gave and the whole thing's quite
complicated but I've got a little thing
that makes it a little bit easier that
you can see that now all kinds of keys
have been added to see the thing
including some to some extent the
packing list of what's in this product
that when you ask for Mathematica
actually I'm gonna get Mathematica I'm
gonna get a service product so now we've
got a complete description of what you
will own all we have to do is basically
copy that into the license database and
it's happy
it's just a copy over and throughout the
keys that that wony transitory and in
the final issue before I wrap up
questions is in the end where as I said
it's eating our own dog food so the
Wolfram language lets us do this whole
symbolic architecture and mix data and
code in subtle ways but then we can push
the thing out into our final deployment
there's no recoding step we just do the
usual thing of a of a cloud deploy of an
API function and now I can access this
thing running off our own enterprise
private cloud that is is on our internal
systems and I can call that form things
like our CRM system from our web
services system from our accounting
package and say for this configuration
we get this JSON response back that I've
decoded being two rules here which is a
number and a currency and that's the
thing then that we have to tell the
credit card company when we're actually
going to execute so like with most
things that whenever you get involved in
technical products you have no idea how
complicated things are if they seem
simple until you actually start coding
so there's all kinds of issues I won't
have a kind of time to talk about how
that execution works and and you know
we've all been having lots of meetings
this week working stuff at those details
out but there are subtleties like time
that you think that we only sell things
monthly annually or perpetually but if
you add an increment to a network
license that you sold eleven months ago
or three months ago you have to add it
for nine months cuz it has to
synchronize so in fact time could be all
kinds of different possibilities and do
you charge the monthly price times nine
or the annual price divided by times
three quarters it's there's a lot of
little corner cases basket optimization
if I buy something with the promo code
but I buy lots of them and the volume
this can actually would have been better
we want to give you the best deal so you
might say I want 50% off and I want a
hundred of these we want to be able say
no we're not going to give you 50% off
like you thought you're going to get
actually but you buy hundred we'll give
you 70% off because it's a volume
discount so figuring out all the
permutations there is quite challenging
and we also want this to be a mechanism
that will also support these
repositories Stephens talked about so
all you do when you create something to
sell through an app store is create a
wall in the colliding tables and the
same engine will will make it possible
to place automatically so you can make a
basket that's got a mathematical init
and some too
a little piece of code you've sold in
the App Store you can make that in one
purchase and it'll it'll just work and
ducky in the moment there were lots of
fun issues to do with trust and
permissions for external clients I would
love it to be the case that one day in
product you could purchase right through
Mathematica for particularly for things
like repository code but also we've got
resellers around the world and what
happens now is they take an order from
you they enter it into their system it
generates a piece of paper or an email
that gets sent to us for us to retype in
to our system and and then execute the
purchase and wouldn't that be lovely if
when they place an order they could call
the API directly and as soon as they've
hit return the thing has been actioned
in our system rather than having a sort
of delay of passing the message down
when you when you buy through a third
party so there are there are lots of
corner cases any one of which I could
give an hour talk about probably and
probably you don't yet fully understand
anyway so be an hour off of not quite
like talk